There are two memory technologies,
SRAM and DRAM.
SRAM stands for
Static Random Access Memory.
DRAM stands for
Dynamic Random Access Memory.
The random access part in both names
simply refers to the fact that we
can access any memory location
by address without needing to go
through all the memory locations.
So random access is as opposed to
sequential access like a tape,
where you have to actually scan through
the whole tape to get somewhere.
With memory, we can arbitrarily
access any part of the memory
without really needing to get to it.
So the only difference between SRAM and
DRAM is this static or dynamic behavior.
Static, in this realm,
refers to the fact that SRAM
retains its data while the power is
supplied, so as long as you connect it
to a power source, it's going to
retain the data that you wrote to it.
It's not going to lose it.
Dynamic, in DRAM,
means that it will lose data,
even while connected to a power source,
unless we refresh the data.
So, pretty much, we need to read out
the data and write it back in, and
keep doing that on a regular basis,
otherwise,
DRAM will simply lose our data.
Note that both of these types
of memory will lose data
when the power is not supplied,
such as when we turn them off.
So it seems like SRAM is better.
We like it, because we don't
have to do anything in order for
it to keep the data, whereas with DRAM,
we actually have to access the data and
write it back in in order for
it to not lose it.
So why do we want to have DRAM?
The answer is that for SRAM,
several transistors are needed for
each bit of SRAM, whereas for DRAM,
we only need one transistor per bit.
So obviously we can get a lot more
DRAM per unit area, than we can SRAM.
So SRAM is good because it retains data,
but bad because it's more expensive.
Here we have to refresh
the data to keep it alive, but
we can cram a lot of
these bits on a chip.
It turns out there is
another difference,
which is SRAM is typically faster and
DRAM is typically slower.
So we get speed, and
simplicity, at more cost.
Or, we can go slower and
need to work at it, but have more bits.